hi i'm hilary mason i'm a computer
scientist and today i've been asked to
explain machine learning in five levels
of increasing complexity machine
learning gives us the ability to learn
things about the world from large
amounts of data that we as human beings
can't possibly study or appreciate so
machine learning is when we teach
computers to learn patterns from looking
at examples in data such that they can
recognize those patterns and apply them
to new things that they haven't seen
before
hi
hi i'm hillary what's your name i'm
brynn do you know what machine learning
means have you heard that before no so
machine learning is a way that we teach
computers to learn things about the
world by looking at patterns and looking
at examples of things so can i show you
an example
of how a machine might learn something
sure so is this a dog or cat it's a dog
and
it's this one a cat and what makes a dog
a dog and a cat a cat well dogs are very
playful i think more than cats cats lick
themselves more than dogs i think
do you think if we look at these
pictures
do you think maybe we could say well
they both have pointy ears but the dogs
have a different kind of body and the
cats like to stand up a little different
do you think that makes sense yeah yeah
what about this one a dog
a cat
i think a cat
because it's more skinny and also its
legs are like really tall
and its ears are a little pointy this
one's a jackal and it's actually a kind
of dog but you made a good guess that's
what machines do too they make guesses
is this a cat or a dog
none none what is it it's humans and how
did you know that it's not a cat or a
dog because cats and dogs because they
walk on their paws and their ears are
like right here not right here and they
don't wear watches
and so you did something pretty amazing
there because we asked the question is
it a cat or a dog and you said i
disagree with your question it's a human
so machine learning is when we teach
machines to make guesses about what
things are based on looking at a lot of
different examples and i build products
that use machine learning to learn about
the world and make guesses about things
in the world when we try to teach
machines to recognize things like cats
and dogs it takes a lot of examples we
have to show them
tens of thousands or even millions of
examples before they can get even close
to as good at it as you are do you have
tests in school
yeah i have after every unit we have a
review and then we have a test are those
like the practice problems you do before
the test well just like everything
that's going to be on the test is on the
review which means that in the test
you're not seeing any problems that you
don't know how to solve
as long as you did all your practice
right yeah so machines work the same way
if you show them a lot of examples and
give them practice they'll learn how to
guess and then when you give them the
test
they should be able to do that so we
looked at eight pictures and you were
able to answer really quickly but what
would you do if i gave you 10 million
examples would you be able to do that so
quickly yeah so one of the differences
between people and machines
is that people
might be a little better at this but
can't look at 10 million different
things now that we've been talking about
machine learning is this something you
want to learn how to do um
kind of because i kind of want to become
a spy
and
we used to do
coding
so i may be kind of good
and machine learning is a great way to
use all those math skills all those
coding skills and would be a super cool
tool for a spy
hello
hi are you a student lucy yes i just
finished ninth grade congratulations
thank you it's very exciting have you
ever heard of machine learning before
i'm going to assume that it means humans
being able to teach
machines or robots how to learn
themselves that's right when we
teach machines to
learn from data to build a model from
that data or a representation of that
and then to make a prediction one of the
places we often find machine learning in
the real world is in things like
recommendation systems so do you have an
artist do you really like yeah melanie
martinez so i'm gonna look up melanie
martinez and it says here if you like
melanie martinez one of the other songs
you might like is by aura do you know
who that is i do not so let's listen to
a hint of this song okay
all right
so why do you think spotify might have
recommended that song well i know that
in melanie martinez's music she used a
lot of the filtered voice to make it
sound very deep and low
and that song had that and that's
actually a really interesting thing to
think about because that creepy vibe is
something that you can perceive and i
can perceive but it's actually really
hard to describe to a machine what do
you think might go into that pitch of
the music if it's really low or if it's
super high it could know that what can
the machine understand it's a great
question the machine can understand
whatever we tell it to understand so
there might be a person thinking about
things like the pitch or the pacing or
the tone
or sometimes machines can figure out
things about music or images or videos
that
we don't tell it to discover but that it
can learn from looking at a lot of
different examples why do you think
companies might use machine learning i
think
things like facebook or instagram they
probably use it to target ads sometimes
the ads you see are really uncanny and i
think that's because they're based on so
much data they know where you live they
know where your device is it's also
important to realize that people in
aggregate are actually pretty
predictable like when we talk to each
other we like to talk about the novel
things like here we're having this
conversation we don't do this every day
but we probably still eat breakfast
we're gonna eat lunch we're gonna eat
dinner you probably are going to the
same home you go to most of the time and
so they're able to take that data that
we already give them and make
predictions based on that as to what ads
they should show us so you're saying i
give them enough data as it is
about what i might be talking about or
thinking about that they can
read my mind
but just use the data that i've already
given them and it almost seems like
that's why yes
to do machine learning we use something
called algorithms have you heard of
algorithms before a
set of steps or a process carried out to
complete something that's right so do
you think that we've been able to teach
machines enough so that they can do
things that even we can't do
and on the opposite side of that do you
think there are things that we can do
that a machine might never be able to do
so there are things that machines are
really great at that humans are actually
not great at imagine watching every
video posted to tick tock every day so
we just don't have enough time to do
that at the rate at which we can
actually watch those videos but a
machine can analyze all of them and then
make recommendations to us and then
thinking about things that
machines are bad at and people are good
at people are really great with only one
or two examples of learning something
new and incorporating that into our
model of the world to make good
decisions whereas machines often need
tens of thousands of examples and that's
not even getting into things like
good judgment because we care about
people because we can imagine
a future that we want to live in that
doesn't exist today and that's something
that is still uniquely human machines
are great at predicting based on what
they've seen in the past but they're not
creative they're not going to invent
they're not going to
you know really change where we're going
to go that's up to us
i'm sunny
and what are you majoring in i study
math and computer science
so in your studies have you learned
about machine learning
yeah i have so
to me machine learning is essentially
exactly what it sounds like it's trying
to teach a machine
specifics about something
by inputting a lot of data points
and slowly
the machine will
build up knowledge about it over time
for example my gmail program i assumed
that there would be a lot of like
machine learning models happening at
once right absolutely and that's a great
example because you have models that are
operating to do things like figure out
if a new email is spam or not so what
would you think about if you were
looking at an email and trying to decide
if it went in one category or another
i'd probably look at certain keywords
maybe if the recipient and sender had
exchanged emails before and what
generally those
fell into in the past so these are
things we would call features we go
through a process where we do feature
engineering where somebody looks at the
example and says okay these are the
things that i think might allow us to
statistically tell the difference from
something in one category versus another
so for example perhaps you don't speak
russian you start getting a lot of email
in russian obviously like the features
that you just described are features
which a person would have had to think
about are there features which like the
machine itself could learn this is a
great question because it really gets to
the difference between some of our
different tools in our machine learning
tool belt in addressing problems like
this so if we were to use a
supervised learning classic
classification approach a person would
need to think about those features and
creatively come up with them an approach
we call the kitchen sink approach which
is just try everything you can possibly
think of and see what works unsupervised
learning where we don't have label data
and we're trying to infer some structure
out of the data as you're projecting
that data into a space and looking for
things like clusters and there's a bunch
of really fun math about how you do that
how you think about distance and by
distance i mean that if we have two data
points in space how do we decide if
they're similar or not and how do
the algorithms themselves usually differ
between unsupervised and supervised
learning supervised learning we have our
labels and we're trying to figure out
what statistically indicates if
something matches one label or another
label unsupervised learning we don't
necessarily have those labels that's the
thing we're trying to discover so
reinforcement learning is another
technique that we use sometimes you can
think about it like a turn in a game and
you can play
you know millions and millions of trials
so that you're able to develop a system
that by experimenting with reinforcement
learning can eventually learn to play
these games pretty successfully deep
learning which is essentially using
neural networks and very large amounts
of data to eventually iterate on a
network structure that can make
predictions with reinforcement learning
versus deep learning it seems to me that
reinforcement learning is it sort of
like the kitchen sink approach that you
were talking about earlier where you're
just kind of trying everything it is but
it also thrives in environments where
you have a decision point a pallet of
actions to choose from and it actually
comes
historically from trying to train a
robot to navigate a room if it bonks
into this chair it can't go forward
anymore and if it falls into that pit
you know it's not going to succeed but
if it keeps exploring it'll eventually
get to the goal oh like roombas yes
oh wow i didn't realize it was that deep
almost is there a situation which you'd
want to use a deep learning algorithm
over a reinforcement learning algorithm
so typically you would choose deep
learning if you have sufficient high
quality data hopefully labeled in a
useful way
if you
really are happy not to necessarily
understand or be able to interpret what
your system is doing or you're willing
to invest in another set of work
afterwards to understand what the system
is doing once you've already trained it
and this also comes down to the fact
that some things are actually really
easy to solve with linear regression or
simple statistical approaches and some
things are impossible what would be the
outcome if you were to choose the quote
unquote wrong approach you build a
system that could actually be useless so
years ago i had a client there was a big
telecom company and they had a data
scientist who built a deep learning
system to predict customer churn
actually was very accurate but it wasn't
useful because nobody knew why the
prediction was what it was so they could
say you know sonny you're likely to quit
next month but they had no idea what to
do about it
and so i think there are a bunch of
failure modes would that be an example
of like linear regression where the
regression is accurate but you know for
marketing purposes it's like if you
don't know why i'm quitting the service
then how can we fix this yeah this is
actually a good example of a very real
world kind of machine learning problem
where the solution to this was to build
an interpretable system on top of the
accurate prediction so not to throw it
away but to do a bunch more work to
figure out the why how can we improve
machine learning algorithms it's
actually uh
fairly new that we're able to solve all
of these problems and start to build
these products and apply it in
businesses and apply it you know
everywhere and so we're still developing
good practices and what it means to be a
professional in machine learning we're
really developing a notion of what good
looks like
i'm in my first year of a phd in
computer science and i'm studying
natural language processing and machine
learning so would you mind telling me a
bit about what you've been working on or
interested in lately i've been looking
at understanding persuasion and online
text and the ways that we might be able
to
automatically detect the intent behind
that persuasion or who it's targeted at
and what makes effective persuasive
techniques so what are some of the
techniques you're applying to look at
that debate data something i'm
interested in exploring is how well it
works to use
deep learning and sort of automatically
extracted features from this text versus
using some of the more traditional
techniques that we have things like
lexicons or some sort of template
matching techniques for extracting
features from text that's a question i'm
just interested in in general when do we
really need deep learning versus when
can we use something that's a little bit
more interpretable something that's been
around for a while do you think there
are going to be general principles that
guide those decisions because right now
it's generally up to the machine
learning engineer to decide what tools
they want to apply i definitely think
there is but i also sort of see it
varying a lot based on the use case
something that kind of
works out of the box and maybe works a
little bit more automatically might be
better and in other cases you do sort of
kind of you want a lot of fine grain
control so is that where some of that
frustration around the lack of
controllability and interpretability
comes from yeah if you're building a
model that just predicts the next thing
based off of everything it's seen from
text online then yeah you're really
going to be replicating whatever that
distribution online is if you train a
model off of language off the internet
it sometimes says uncomfortable things
or inappropriate things and sometimes
really biased things have you ever run
into this yourself and then how do you
think about that problem of
potentially even measuring the bias in a
model that we've trained
yeah it's a really tricky question as
you said these models are trained to
sort of predict the next sequence of
words given a certain sequence of words
so we could start with just sort of
prompts like the woman was versus the
man was and kind of pull out common
words that are sort of more used with
one phrase versus the other so that's
sort of a qualitative way of looking at
it it's not ever kind of a guarantee of
how the model is going to behave in one
particular instance and i think that's
what's
really tricky and that's why i sort of
think it's really good for
creators of systems to just be honest
about this is sort of what we have seen
and so then someone can make their own
judgment about is this going to be too
high risk for sort of my particular use
case i imagine in the last few years
we've seen a lot of changes and
improvements in the capabilities of nlp
systems so is there anything in that
that you're particularly excited about
exploring further i'm
really interested in
sort of the
creative potential that we've started to
see from nlp systems with things like
gpd3 and other really powerful language
models it's really easy to write long
grammatical passages thinking about the
way that we can then harness like the
human ability to actually give meaning
to those words and sort of provide
structure and how we can combine those
things with the kind of like generative
capabilities of these models now is
really interesting yeah i agree
[Music]
so hi claudia it's so great to see you
it's been far too long you know we first
met 10 11 years ago and machine learning
has changed a lot since then tooling
that we now have the capacity and also
an elevation of the problem sets that
we're dealing with and how to frame the
problem
and i'm
almost struggling to figure out whether
it's a blessing or a curse that it has
become as accessible and as democratized
and as
easy to execute and you just build
another new company from scratch but so
what's been kind of your reflection on
that well you're absolutely right that
the attention machine learning gets has
grown dramatically 20 years ago going to
gatherings and telling people what i was
working on and how to seeing the blank
face or the like where's the turn and
walk away like oh no
the accessibility of the tooling like we
can now do in like five lines of code
something that would have taken 500
lines of very mathematical messy gnarly
code even you know five years ago and
it's not an exaggeration and there are
tools that mean that pretty much anyone
can pick this up and start playing with
it and start to build with it and that
is also really exciting in contrast what
i'm struggling with the friend of mine
who asked me to look at some healthcare
data for him
and despite the capabilities that we're
having in all of the kind of bigger
societal problems alongside with
data collection engineering all the
gnarly stuff that is actually not the
machine learning itself
it's the rest of it where certain data
isn't available and to me it's
staggering how difficult it is to get it
off the ground and actually use and
part of the challenge of it is not the
mathematics of building models but the
challenge is making sure that the data
is sufficiently representative
potentially high quality but how
transparent do i need to build it for it
to be adopted at some point what types
of
biases in the data collection and then
also in the usage we now call it the
bias but we're still struggling with the
society
not really living up to his expectations
and then machine learning bringing it to
the forefront right and so to say that
another way when you're collecting data
from the real world and then building
machine learning systems that automate
decisions based on that data all of the
biases and problems that are already in
the real world then can be magnified
through that machine learning system and
so it can make many of these problems
much worse feeling increasingly
challenged
that
my skill set of being very good at
programming has become somewhat
secondary and it's really
it's really the bigger picture
understanding of who would be using that
how transparent do i need to build it
for it to be adopted at some point what
types of
biases in the data collection and then
also in the usage i think in certain
areas we have societal expectations as
to what is fair and what isn't
and so it's not just the provenance of
that data but it's sort of deeply
understanding why does it look the way
it looks why was it collected this way
what are the limitations of it we need
to think about that in
entire process how we document that
process this is an issue in companies
where somebody might create something
that even their peers can't recreate
what have you seen in terms of which
industries where they stand like who is
adopting now who is ready to utilize it
where would you maybe wish they didn't
even try
these are great questions so things like
actuarial science operations research
where they actually are not using
machine learning as much as you might
think and then you have other sorts of
companies or on the fintech side or even
the ad tech side of things where they
perhaps are using machine learning um to
the point of even absurdity so i spent
about eight years
working in atec and
the motivation was really because it was
such an amazingly exciting playground to
push that technology that used to
largely live in academia really
out in the world and see kind of what it
can achieve it has created such a hunger
for data that now
everything is being collected i'm
curious when are we going to
make a foray into things like
agriculture about
smart production of the things we eat
you see and hear these interesting
stories but i feel like we're not ready
yet to put that into a economically
viable situation so when we think about
the next five to ten years the things
that are really still holding us back
are these uneven applications of
resources to problems because the
problems that get attention are the high
value ones in terms of how much money
you can make or the things that are
fashionable enough that you can publish
a paper on it so what do you think is
holding us back i fully agree on the
steps you pointed out and and the
processes i think there is a chicken and
neck problem like your former example
that these areas that need to wait
for data
the value of the data collection is then
also slightly less
apparent and so it gets delayed further
and you see that happening but what my
experience has been
yes unfortunately i feel a
drifting apart between academia and the
uses of ai but i'm
somewhat frustrated with a generation of
students who have standard data sets
that they never think about what the
model needs to be used for
that they never have to think about how
the data was collected so with all these
challenges ahead of us how optimistic
are you about
this world that
i deeply believe we can uh create
and the steps towards it
i am incredibly optimistic and uh
perhaps it's a personality flaw but i
can't help but look at
the potential of the technology to
reduce harm to give us information to
help us make better decisions and to
think that we would choose
to address the big problems ahead of us
i don't think we have a hope of
addressing them without figuring out the
role that machine learning will play and
to think that we would then choose not
to do that is just unthinkable despite
the rightfully
concerns about the challenges ahead but
i think
they also make us a society better they
challenge us to be a lot clearer of
what fairness means to us means to all
of us so with all of the setbacks
i think we have exciting years to come
and
i am looking forward to a world where a
lot more of that is
used for the right purposes
[Music]
i hope you learned something about
machine learning there has never been a
better time to study machine learning
because you're now able to build
products that have tremendous potential
and impact across any industry or area
that you might be excited about
[Music]